Eh bien bonjour, peuple de Youtube
Et bienvenue dans ce cinquième et avant-dernier épisode de notre let's play sur Outlast 2
On commence direct mec
Souvenez-vous, on s'était fait enterré dans un put*in de cercueil
Euh... qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire pour sortir de là ?
Il... Il va pousser...
Oh put*in (Anxiété)
*Bruit de clavier ou de souris répété*
Ooh ! Quel homme put*in
Okay, mec
Là, il faut arrêter les conn*ries parce qu'ils vont essayer de revenir vite...
Faut qu'on se casse !
(Halètements de Blake)
Ohhh. What the fu...
Oh non, il y a encore les put*ins de trucs qui rampent
Il rampe vers moi ou il rampe juste histoire de ramper
Ou parce qu'il a envie de ramper, car c'est sa passion de ramper comme ça ?
Chais pas
Mais j'propose qu'on se casse !
A mon avis c'est par ici je le sens bien
La où il y avait des fougères,
là bas
tout droit
En fait c'est où on avait retrouvé un chemin comme ça dans la fôret ?
WOW !!!!
Y a des y a des, puta*ns de créatures partout mec....
Ah elle me blesse....
OOOOH !!!!! *Screamer*
Pu*ain de merde.....
fils de p*te
enc*lé de rampant
*bruit de pas*
vas-y allonge toi ,allonge toi ,allonge toi !
*rampe*
ah p*tain j'ai un bandage ?
YES  ! j'ai un bandage je vais me bander !
ok nikel alors
y a une page j'la prend en photo et je me casse
y a des,y a des bruit ?
y a des bruit d'un mec ?
Là ?
Oh non, oh nooooon non non non non
J'aime pas moi quand c'est comme ça par terre,
j'aime pas du tout...
On va se diriger vers la fenêtre ouverte
Hein?
La petit fenêtre ouverte dans la salle de classe au décor normal...
Où rien ne va pas...
Où tout va bien plutôt.
Voiiilà là on est bien!
Ici nous sommes bien, nous sommes en paix
Voilà
Ici le moment pour boire un peu de : San Pe' !
C'était pour la rime
On y va !
*parle anglais* Nobody's here
Yes I speakeuh a little bit engeulish
Huuum
Hum hum
Plein de Jessicas pendues
Ça fait pas plaisir
J'sais pas par où il faut aller hein, je tente des choses
Oh put*in mais ya des Jess pendues
Oooh une histoire
*caméra qui grésille*
Non c'est abstrait ce qu'il dit
Comme d'hab hein les vidéos dans les souvenirs,
ça ne marche pas !
Et là y'avait un monstre qui allait à droite...
Je...
Il fait quelque chose, j'sais pas c'qui fait mais il fait quelque chose
En tout cas on va devoir le rejoindre par cette porte..
Qui bien sûr s'ouvre parce que c'est le chemin... à prendre !
Et on est pas content,
de la prendre !
J
I, K
L, V
BLAK
D'accord !
*bruit de porte qui s'ouvre*
Des photos de campagne présidentielle !
Oh mais mon ombre mec, elle est...
Elle fait put'
Non mais mec, faut pas que j'aille là-bas..
Ya...
Ya le monstre...
OOH!
L'OMBRE VIENT À MOI L'OMBRE VIENT À MOI !!
Sale...
*Porte verrouillée*
Chui mort
*Chuchote* Ça m'a tendu...
J'suis pas bien...
*Voix normale* Bon c'est par là du coup?
Ah oui bah oui la porte c'est ouverte maintenant...
Put*in...
Oh put*in...
Une croix qui saigne...
Vraiment...
On en est là...
La librairie...
Oh oui j'arrive en enfonçant la porte !
Qu'es'qui s'passe ?
Qu'est-ce que tu vas faire Jessica !?
On va faire le tour, on va voir hein 'tain
Ah mais regardez vers la gauche
c'est hyper profond...
Put*in elle est immense cette bibliothèque !
Abusé !
Ils ont eu tous 20/20 avec un stock de tr...
Sale p*te
C'est sorti tout seul pardon
Tu veux pas me...
Mais tu veux pas me laisser genre en paix?
Mais tu veux pas me laisser en paix ! Mais j'suis choqué !!
Par là...
Vers le chemin annexe...
*respiration de Blake*
C'est un vrai labyrinthe hein
ça c'est vraiment pas cool...
Bah voilà...
On part sur un gros cul-de-sac.
Allez, on peut le faire,
Sale p*te.
Non ça c'était une vision, ça c'est une vision...
Putain mais c'est dur !
Des fois je sais pas si c'est une vision !
Des fois je sais pas si c'est vraiment elle !
Préparez-vous au screamer les amis.
Attention j'suis sympa j'vous l'dis.
Vous pouvez me faire confiance, ça sent le screamer...
Ok c'est par là.
Eeew
Il s'est passé quoi, j'suis où ?
Ok j'suis allongé.
Allez, on y va, on y va !
Oh put*in mais là mec t'as vraiment 20/20.
Et c'est la porte!
Voooilà !
Avec le bandage...
Parce que bien sûr on va se prendre 18 coups.
Ah!
Je peux pas mettre plus de bandages !
Ça c'est très badant.
*IL ARRIVE*
Ok
Qui est "il" ? Dans l'histoire...
Qu'est-ce qui me bloque? Des livres,
J'me fais bloquer par des livres put*in...
C'est très très beau ces jeux de lumières...
Mais ce jeu avec... ce fantôme, l'est  beaucoup moins
*Cri de Jessica*
*Blake : M*rde !!*
*Cris de Jessica*
J'arrive j'arrive, je te suis, montre-moi !! Montre-moi la voie !!!
* Pleurs de Jessica*
* S'il-te-plait Blake !*
Où est-ce que t'es ?!
*Cris de Blake*
Put*in.
Put*in ok.
Très belle transition une fois de plus...
Très belle transition une fois de plus, faut que j'aille...
Là-haut.
Quelque part là-haut.
C'est évident.
Ça va de soit.
*Bruit de chariot qu'on déplace*
Non? On sait pas?
Si c'est bon, si ça marche
Pour retourner de l'autre côté
Choper ce bandage que je ne peux pas mettre car j'ai TROP de bandages !
Ça ne nous est jamais arrivé...
'fin apart une fois dans l'épisode 1, j'crois...
Tsé quand ils te refilent 10 000 bandages...
*Cris dans le lointain*
OH P'
*grognements de zombies*
'tain ça me fout le cafard là
*Bruit de porte qui grince*
Rha ça commence à me foutre le cafarde violent mon gars...
Ils veulent pas me laisser tranquille 2 secondes
* Rires sauvages de zombies*
OH UNE PILE !
Ça, ça me fait plaisir.
* Bruits de zombies*
Ah non mais là, c'est des bruits de Leftovers 2 les mecs, arrêtez...
Vous êtes des zombies, vous êtes, vous êtes quoi?
Ah merde !
C'est les pires portes ça hein
Chépas qui a inventé ces portes mais il faut le...
Il faut le bannir.
En tout cas je lui interdis de regarder le Let's play...
de son propre jeu.
Ok j'ai ça
Faut que je le mette où ?
*Bruits de zombies*
Ah... Attends faut que j'aille où ?
Oh putain...
Ça zone là-haut?
Ok en fait c'est en hauteur
du coup j'ai moins peur...
Ah ok faut aller là.
*Bruit de chariot*
Ok
*Zombies*
OH LES PUTAINS ILS SONT DESCENDUS LES FILS DE P*TES
C'est bon !!
Oh putain ! Pardon !
Oh pardon !
Ooooh !
Ooooooh
*Musique stressante*
(Plainte) Chui pas venu pour souffrir ok?
*Blake : Ah ! Ah !*
*Grognements de Blake*
Rha cette transition mon gars
*Blake : Merde ! (Désespéré) *
Damn it
Sorry !
Là le truc me suit mec, mais genre, il me suit...
mais à... d'une puissance colossale !
Et à mon avis c'est comme d'hab
Faut aller là où il a...
le chemin et...
Là où elle est apparue, le...
le... la... la...
Le vilain monstre finalement !
Euuuh
Donc voilà, faut que je la sème !
Et comment je vais pouvoir la semer ?
C'est une bonne quest.. Ah bah avec des chiottes !
Allez j't'ai semé, j't'ai semé, fais pas genre...
Je sais que je t'ai semé.
Au fond de toi tu...
* Chansonnette sur l'air de "si tu aimes le soleil" : Gare à ce que vous voyez, petits yeux.*
*Gare à ce que vous voyez, petits yeux.*
* Car le Père est tout là-haut. *
* Nous regarde avec amour. *
* Gare à ce que vous voyez, petits yeux.*
*Gare à ce que vous touchez, petites mains.*
* Gare à ce que vous touchez, petites mains.
* Car le Père est tout là-haut.*
* Nous regarde avec amour.*
* Gare à ce que vous touchez, petites mains. *
*Bruits de pas*
* Gare à tout ce que tu dis, petite bouche. *
* Gare à tout ce que tu dis, petite bouche.*
* Car le Père est tout là-haut.
* Nous regarde avec amour. *
* Gare à tout ce que tu dis, petite bouche.*
*Bruits de portes qui claquent*
"I can't feel my face when I'm with you"
Voilà c'est pour se détendre ça...
J'vais là. J'vais là.
Je vais me lever je vais me barrer direct.
Vous êtes prêts ?
*BRUIT STRESSANT*
Let's do this !
Tous ensemble, tous ensemble *rire nerveux*
On peut !
Tous ensem... *rire nerveux*
Faut que je trouve les marches
Yes !
Et du coup je peux passer?
Ya une pendue, bien sûr, qui s'appelle Jessica.
On connaît son nom par cœur maintenant depuis le temps.
* Voix d'homme : Tu n'es pas méchant Blake, juste désorienté.*
Désorienté, d'accord.
* Tu n'as pas à te cacher.*
*Laisse-moi t'aider...*
Fils de p*te
Donc c'est le...
Est-ce qu'on est pas...
Est-ce que c'est pas le classique coup du...
du prêtre pédophile là, en fait, l'histoire.
Je crois que c'est ça.
I'll never let you go
"Je ne te laisserai jamais partir"
Bah écoute c'est, ça me fait plaisir,
que tu me dises ça.
Ce qui est faux
Fenêtre
Ok
Fiou
ET BEN LES AMIS !
Je crois qu'on a assez joué pour cet épisode, on a même trop joué pour cet épisode !
Il était éprouvant mon gars
Aaah
J'sais pas si c'est parce que j'étais plus à fleur de peau
que d'habitude,
mais mec, il m'a particulièrement mis mal, quoi.
Et ben n'hésitez pas à l'aimer s'il vous à plus !
Et on se retrouve, les amis, samedi, pour le tout dernier épisode du Let's play !
On saura enfin ce qui est arrivé à Lynn,
ce qui est arrivé à Jessica, même si ça semble être la piste du prêtre pédophile un peu,
Euh voilà!
J'vous fait plein de gros bisous, je vous dis à très vite dans une prochaine vidéo !
Portez-vous bien.
Au revoir!